تشير الأبحاث إلى أن الحيوانات الأليفة يمكن أن تكون
مفيدة للحيوانات الأليفة التي تساعد في تقليل
مستويات الكوليسترول في الدم وضغط الدم
ومستويات الدهون الثلاثية وتقليل
الشعور بالوحدة يمكن للحيوانات الأليفة أيضًا تحسين صحتك عن
طريق دفعك للخارج
لممارسة الرياضة والأنشطة الأخرى التي يمكن أن
تزيد من فرصك في
التنشئة الاجتماعية والمساعدة  يمكنك تكوين صداقات جديدة
خاصةً إذا كان حيوانك الأليف كلبًا ،
وجدت دراسة واحدة بتمويل من
المعهد الوطني للصحة أن
أصحاب الكلاب الذين أصيبوا بنوبات قلبية
كانوا أكثر عرضة للبقاء على قيد الحياة
بعد عام واحد ، ويمكن للكلاب أن تؤثر على
التطور العاطفي والمعرفي لدى
الأطفال.  يُظهر رفقاء رائعون
للبحث من قبل مركز السيطرة على الأمراض أنهم يستطيعون
تحسين الحالة المزاجية ، وتوفير الدعم العاطفي
وتعزيز الروح المعنوية العامة
لأصحابها ، ويُنسب الفضل في تعزيز
التنشئة الاجتماعية بين
الأشخاص المعاقين جسديًا أو عقليًا وكبار السن ،
ولكن إذا احتفظت بالحيوانات الأليفة في منزلك ،
فيجب عليك التأكد  تحصل على
رعاية بيطرية روتينية لهم وتأكد أيضًا
من ذ  تقوم دائمًا بتنظيف يديك بعد
ملامسة حيواناتك الأليفة لمخلفاتها
أو طعامها للحظة الصحية اليوم
أنا كيم هاتشرسون